hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast impulse control disorders
behavioral addictions insights from
dopaminergic medication related
behaviors in Parkinson's disease
presented by dr. Valerie moon I'm Julia
Child some lab and I'll be your
moderator for today's presentation we
are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
elaborates the leading scientific social
networking site and provider of virtual
events and webinars advanced in
scientific collaboration and learning we
apologize that we are not doing the Q&A
for this presentation please notice that
you will be viewing the presentation in
the slide window so enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem this is an
educational webinar and this provides
three continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
C e button located on the bottom
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits now I'd like to introduce dr.
Valerie Boone dr. Valerie Byrne is a
neuropsychiatrist and principal
investigator in the department of
psychiatry at the University of
Cambridge she completed her medical
degree at the University of British
Columbia in psychiatry residency at the
University of Toronto her PhD in
neuroscience jointly through the
University College London and National
Institute of Neurological Disorders and
Stroke focused on mechanisms underlying
dopaminergic medication induced impulse
control disorders in Parkinson's disease
she has been a Wellcome Trust fellow in
clinical neurosciences for the last five
years at the University of Cambridge dr.
Gunes research group focuses on
mechanisms underlying impulsivity
compulsivity and relevance to disorders
of addiction across both drug and
natural rewards she uses a multi model
approach including an Tim nickel and
functional MRI
94 illogical challenges computational
modeling and cognitive neuroscience she
has published extensively with over a
hundred peer-reviewed publications
including in high-impact journals such
as neuron Molecular Psychiatry Lancet
neurology and also neurology rain and
biology psychiatry and she's a fellow of
the American neuropsychiatric
Association please join me in welcoming
dr. bin
well thanks so much and to the
organizers for the invitation to speak
it is very much a pleasure to be here
and to be able to talk about this
particular topic so I'm going to be
talking about impulse control disorders
or also known as behavioral addictions
related to the dopaminergic medications
and Parkinson's disease you know see
there's a range of different behaviors
that are related so we see things like
pathological gambling compulsive sexual
behaviors that you see binge eating
behaviors and also compulsive shopping I
realize that this is a bit of a
sensationalist slide it does come from
the daily now and this is actually
someone who was involved in the
class-action lawsuit related to a
dopamine agonist you can see those
titles as Parkinson's medication turning
into the gambling gay sex thief but in
fact there are very real consequences to
these behaviors related to the
dopaminergic medications and in this
particular case this person was gambling
lost up to 130,000 euros related to the
dopaminergic medications started
exposing himself cross-dressing and was
getting into trouble sexually indeed in
previous class action lawsuits at least
in one case there was 8.2 million
dollars the u.s. it was awarded in a
case in Minneapolis and there are now
with the FDA they are warnings with
regards to these behaviors being related
to the dopamine agonists
so just so everybody is on the same page
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
explain a little bit about the
background of Parkinson's disease and
just give you just sort of a bit of
context and so Parkinson's disease is
classically a disorder of movements and
so you get this tremor Braddock high
major rigidity but now we understand it
as actually much more broad than that
it's a neuropsychiatric disorder with
clear-cut cognitive components
neuropsychiatric aspects
again with regards to the underlying
that neurodegeneration you get
classically again neurodegeneration
affecting substantial [ __ ] pars
compacta and that with nurtured
regeneration the dopaminergic cell
bodies which project the motor regions
and much more variably and much more
intent is the ventral tegmental area
which project more into little bit
regions what we also understand now
about Parkinson's is that it's gone we
understand it beyond just two
dopaminergic etiology I made this clear
cut neuro degeneration affecting certain
merging systems nor adrenergic systems
gnosis acetylcholine but in this
particular case and for the purposes of
this talk we're going to focus in
particularly on the dopaminergic system
let me just describe a little bit about
the dopaminergic medications also we're
going to talk more about Viva Doha and
also the dopamine agonists but just
again so everyone's on the same page
levodopa is a precursor of dopamine so
it is process than to do I mean you're
broken down into dopamine
so it can act both interest-only and
also extracellular lee and in contrast
opinion agonists act on the presynaptic
or the postsynaptic dopamine receptors
so you can see in this case either on
the presynaptic d2 on a receptor or any
of the postsynaptic adrenergic receptors
there's a range of dopamine agonists
that are available the ones that you're
going to hear about it will include
pramipexole or a pin rule you can see
here that is greater perhaps d2 d3
affinity for pramipexole ro control as
compared to some of the other ones which
have perhaps a little bit more d1 as
relative to d2 d3 now how frequent are
these behaviors in the context of
Parkinson's disease abysus a Dominion
study which is a multicenter study
involving over 3,000 patients
that took place in North America this
was a very large sample size and what we
see here is that they do the behaviors
occurred in 30 minutes six patients so
that's actually 14% in subjects who were
diagnosed with Parkinson's disease and
more on dopaminergic medications they
can see it's broken up into a range of
different frequencies with problem
gambling hyper sexuality compulsive
shopping and binge eating disorder
reasonably equally in terms of
distribution it's actually not that much
different from what you'd expect to see
in the general population as you can see
the general population figures in the
next column long term I think the key
thing is actually when it actually
occurs so in the context of problem
gambling for instance gambling after the
age of 55 is actually not that common
you can see here it occurs in a general
population and about 13.4% and in
contrast these behaviors are new onset
in these in these Parkinson's patients
in the occur in the context of having
been exposed to dopaminergic and to
doing energic agents and not necessarily
prior to this so there is something
unusual about at the onset occurring at
a much later age associated with the
dopaminergic medications in terms of the
phenomenology or holiday presents
there's certain behaviors that lengthen
so things like the people being very
preoccupied or the behaviors the unable
to control the urges they're persistent
and that the significant consequences so
in a study that we conducted in Canada
the mean amount that was lost was
actually a hundred and thousand u.s.
that sort of Canadian dollars so
certainly it can have significant
financial consequences and certainly the
kind of marital and social causes
effects consequences can also be marked
now again this is from the Dominion
study in terms of it's looking at the
associate
with energy medications so here we see
that the impulse control behaviors have
a very clear-cut association with
dopamine agonists and the odds ratio
there is 2.72 you can see that it occurs
across all the different behaviors so
all the different I CDs is not specific
to any of them
there's also a very clear-cut
Association an independent association
with just the presence of levodopa alone
so the presence of levodopa nom is an
independent predictor and the dose of
maybe dope is also an independent
predictor so there's something beyond
just dopamine agonists there is indeed
in the Association also there's also
been identified a range or different
associated factors so again this is from
the Dominions study and what we see here
is associated factors actually look
remarkably similar to what you'd expect
associated with pathological gambling in
the general population so things like a
family history of gambling smoking
behaviors alcohol use disorders this a
little bit mixed mainly because it tends
to co-occur with all the other behaviors
so it's not necessarily an independent
associated factor 7 we see and
significant levels of depression high
novelty seeking and high impulsivity and
all of these are very much related to
what you'd see in terms of associated
factors in pathological gambling in the
general population it's a very much
suggesting that there might be similar
overlapping neural substrates or that
this is a role for individual
susceptibility and one of the remarkable
things about this is in part that this
actually a range of people who are on
these medications at similar doses and
what is it that makes one person develop
this behavior but not another person so
what is it about that 14% that develop
these behaviors and then the other
component is why does someone develop
one day
not another behavior so why buying
behaviors or binge eating or hyper
sexual and in not another one
and we are starting to kinda understand
a little bit surrounding this so these
are the gender proportions and again
this is from the dominium study and what
we see here is that men in red are more
likely to express compulsive sexual
behaviors as compared to the women in
black were much more likely to express
buying behaviors and binge eating
behaviors and indeed this is actually
similar to what you'd expect to see in
the general population in terms of the
proportions in terms of the gender
proportions again you also see
differences in terms of novelty seeking
and novelty seeking is a trades and it's
also associated with substance use
disorders and the way we can one of the
ways in which we can assess and very
classically is through questionnaires
there's types of questions we ask people
would be things like do you often try
new things for fun of thrills and do you
like to do things that without regard
for strict rules and regulations in fact
what we end up seeing is that
pathological gamblers and compulsive
shoppers again this is from the
Dominions study what we see is that
those two groups are elevated in terms
of novelty sneaking compared to
Parkinson's controls without impulse
control behaviors and in contrast you
don't see that with hypersexuality of
binge eating so suggesting that there
are certain subgroup differences that
might play itself errors in terms of why
someone might develop a specific
behavior not another we're gonna talk a
little bit more about this at a later
stage okay so just to kind of put things
into context a little bit we're gonna be
the way I sort of conceptualize these
behaviors is a relationship between what
is the underlying Parkinson's this is a
role for Parkinson's disease the
underlying neural
ology indeed one of the more recent
studies would suggest that there may
indeed be a little Parkinson's disease
and we're going to talk a little bit
about that is there a role for
individual susceptibility I think we've
already discussed that potentially there
may be underlying individual
susceptibilities in terms of why the
certain proportion may develop these
behaviors but not necessarily the all
the people who are exposed to dopamine
agonists and certainly there is this
interaction between the dopaminergic
medications and either the two other
factors so I'm going to start by asking
what is the role of Parkinson's disease
and again as I mentioned before there is
this imbalance between dorsal striatum
and ventral striatum regions or
substantial Niagra versus ventral
tegmental area regions and at this
you'll see this predominantly in terms
of rodent studies and we'll talk about
the reinforcing properties of
dopaminergic medications we'll talk a
little bit about how dopamine function
is affected and then what specific
cognitive processes may be affected so
here we're going to talk a little bit
about the role of reward to use learning
from feedback and a few different
subtypes of impulsivity I don't have the
time to talk about the rule of supply
make deep brain stimulation but
certainly that's something that I would
be happy to answer at a later stage so
let's start by asking is there a role
for Parkinson's disease and indeed this
is new data within the last several
years mostly from rodent studies there's
kind of twos two sets of people have
been studying it include Celeste
Napier's group and Pierre Olivier and
Bernadette and what they've been showing
is potentially an influence of the
parkinsonian rodent model particularly
on reinforcement reinforcing behaviors
or reinforcement
sorry reinforcing behaviors related to
the dopaminergic medications so in this
particular study and what we're seeing
here is
six hydroxy dopamine infused into the
dorsal lateral stride and that results
in neuro degeneration specific to the
substantia [ __ ] pars compacta about 50%
neurodegeneration whereas the VTA itself
remains intact what they then did was
they looked at the condition police
preference for pramipexole so does a
rodent prefer the chamber that's been
conditioned to pramipexole or condition
to same name and what you see here is
that the lesions the the rodents who
have had the lesion in the dorsal
lateral striatum have his preferences
condition placed preference towards
pranitha the pramipexole condition chain
worm and you see that it's not
significant in the shan lesion whereas
if you increase the dose of contacts or
sufficiently you do actually see that
the Rowett Institute have overall a
preference for a condition placed
preference for the pramipexole condition
chamber this is a slightly different
study and this in this particular one
the six hydroxy dopamine was then
infused into the substandard [ __ ] pars
compacta
and what we see here then is lesions
affecting 51 percent of the tyrosine
hydroxylase positive cells for the
dopaminergic cells in the substantia
[ __ ] pars compacta but it also affects
the ventral tegmental area 32% so
suggesting that there isn't the same
kind of imbalance between the substantia
[ __ ] in the ventral tegmental area but
in this particular study then what you
see is a measure of progressive issues
so looking at the final ratio so how
hard is the rodent willing toward for
the some in terms of lead represses
and overall you see that there is an
increase in the final ratio so the
breakpoint is about 5'4 pramipexole and
indeed it's actually quite a bit higher
for things like cocaine it's about a
hundred but it is indeed elevated but
there's no clear-cut affective illusion
cerpac so little
forcing certainly not not by any means
close that anywhere close to cocaine but
it's also no effect of the parkinsonian
region itself what the authors do see
though is that this greater delta force
be accumulation in the neurons
particularly within the media striatum
in the envisioned rodents if you look
specifically lesion rodents and you look
at the relationship between this
progressive ratio the final ratio and
delta force be accumulation you see
that's actually a positive correlation
between the accumulation in the nucleus
accumbens core and this willingness to
work for pramipexole so this is kind of
relationship between this molecular
marker and this willingness to work not
for the drug and Delta false P is well
known to be associated with substances
or drugs of abuse what about in terms of
levodopa there is actually a
relationship also with leave it open and
again using a parkinsonian rodent model
a slightly different version this time
where they have a vector that over
expresses alpha synuclein human alpha
synuclein and infuse this really inject
this within the substantia [ __ ] pars
compacta you can see that there is
specific neuro degeneration of the
dopaminergic neurons in the substantia
[ __ ] without affecting the ventral
tegmental area and here the authors have
looked at the CPP score the condition
based preference for you can see that
the Roda prefers the chamber has been
associated with levodopa rather than
shown or vehicle
I think this didn't show up very well
but what they also show was actually
didn't show up very well at all but what
they also show is that the rodents
that's been mentioned also has a
decreased preference
so dangerous intake of sweetened water
so there's non-drug award so this is the
idea that the rodents actually has a
preference and as higher reinforcement
value on the drug itself which in this
case is maybe dope but less less
incentive or salience to take a non drug
reward so in this case we water so just
as an interim summary of this section we
do say clear-cut effective Loudoun
models for old parkinson's disease in
this imbalance between particularly
dorsal lateral striatal systems and and
the and the ventral striatum were more
particularly perhaps more substantial
[ __ ] pars compacta and ventral
tegmental area and this plays a role in
terms of increasing condition place
preference but not necessarily the
willingness to work for pramipexole you
see this increase in delta falls the
accumulation the medial striatum and
particularly the lesion road and see see
this relationship between this
willingness to work weather behavior and
associated with delta Foskey
accumulation the makers accumbens corn
and this isn't restricted only to Planet
X all we also see greater reinforcement
value associated with levodopa with
increases in CPP okay so let's go on to
ask how dopamine function is itself is
affected and here we're going to focus
in particularly on one phase of dopamine
rather than tonic dopamine certainly
does a whole range of different
behaviors it could be taking place with
regards to tonic to opening but for the
purposes of this talk we're going to
focus in on phase of dopamine and physic
dopamine encodes
something called prediction error so
this is the difference between actually
experiencing or the actual outcome
versus what you think you're going to
get
what your predict you're going to get
and that acts as a teaching signal so
let me walk you through this so what
happens if you see for instance an ad
for a restaurant and you've never been
to this restaurant before you go to the
restaurant turns out it's amazing so you
get this phasic increase in dopamine at
the time that you're in the restaurant
and it teaches you then the next time
you see this and perhaps you should
consider changing your preferences or
changing your choices and going to this
restaurant and as the ad is associated
or you learn this association the basic
dopamine signal moves much more early in
time and is then associated with a
prediction itself or the ad now what
happens you then go to this restaurant
and you have this horrible time you then
end up with this phasic decrease in
dopamine or a pause and dopamine
activity and that acts as a negative
prediction error signal so telling you
the next time perhaps you see this and
you may not want to go to this
restaurant and there's some evidence to
suggest that perhaps these phasic
increases in dopamine which again act as
a teaching signal may be more likely to
to be to engage d1 and d2 receptors
given their affinity but that the atonic
activity in particular these pauses in
activity and the negative prediction
error may be more likely to engage the
d2 receptors which are much more high
affinity and what has also been
postulated or hypothesized is that the
dopamine agonists may indeed be
specifically impairing negative
prediction error signals now there's
some very nice evidence from rodents and
looking at underlying physiology to
suggest that chronic there's differences
between acute dopaminergic medications
and chronically najuk medications and in
this particular study we're looking at
the rule of acute versus chronic
levodopa
so what we see here is whenever when a
rodents is exposed to an external
stimulus as potentially rewarding only a
certain proportion of cells are capable
of eliciting of phasic dopamine response
and though that proportion is a
spontaneously active proportion and so
you can see here that approximately 50%
of these cells in orange here on the top
in the context of chronic levodopa we
then end up with this increased
proportion of cells that are
dopaminergic neurons that are
spontaneously active were then capable
for then eliciting aphasic dopamine
response indeed this is work from Tony
graces group and what you see here is an
intact intact animal we also see here a
parkinsonian rodent model and what
you've done is looked at the effects of
acutely the dopa but also chronic leave
it open you can see that chronic
levodopa is associated with an increased
proportion of spontaneously active
dopamine neurons as compared to acute
levodopa indeed we see a somewhat
different somewhat similar pattern in
response to the cute versus chronic
pramipexole and here we're looking at
the mean rate of firing a dopamine and
what you see is that with the coupon
pixel you get this decrease in the mean
rate of firing and dopamine neurons
whereas with chronic it normalizes to
actually very close to that of that of
baseline in both of these and this kind
of elevation or increase in the context
of chronic administration has been shown
to be associated with the two auto
receptor and regulation so what this
tells us then is in the context of
chronic levodopa what happens is that
this is increase in the proportion of
spontaneously active dopamine neurons or
the neurons are capable of firing a
phase that dopamine signal in the
context of and
an unexpected reward so what you then
get is potentially an increase in the
physiological activity or the
physiological number of neurons that are
capable of firing with with these phasic
rewards or with this phasic activity
there's two other pieces of the puzzle
that are worth mentioning so again this
one is in the context again the d2
autumn etcetera and I'd mentioned before
that a d2 auto receptor down regulation
may be playing a role in terms of this
kind of chronic the differences between
the two versus chronic administration
under the energy of medications and
there is actually evidence in human
studies so this is now Parkinson's
patients with impulse control behaviors
and this is work from Antonio stuff
Illustrated and what he's shown again it
is a slightly it's a smaller sample size
but what he's showing is he's looked at
eleven carbon flb four five seven which
is a ligand that binds outside of
Australian so in this case are looking
specifically in the membrane and it's
binding to detune receptors so
presumably presynaptic on d2 auto
receptors it's a little bit of a
complicated slides are going to walk you
through it so on the left here are these
Parkinson's controls so with the
Parkinson's patients without gambling
symptoms as compared to those with
gambling symptoms and what you see is
what the Parkinson's patients are either
scanned with FLP four five seven or else
they are scanned while they're playing a
gambling task and it's been shown in
previous studies that playing the Slamon
task is associated with an increase in
release and ventral striatum dopamine so
what happens is the ventral straddle
dopamine then binds to the presynaptic
d2 Auto receptor and there's this
decrease in the binding potential of the
FLV four five seven ligand so that's why
in the control group you see this
decrease with a gray bar being lower
than the white bar
but in the gambling maybe I should don't
see this so indeed in the gambling but
then and this group is also shown that
when they're playing this gambling test
you get this increase in ventral
striatum really so in fact you should
actually see a greater decrease in the
binding potential of FL be four five
seven but you don't see it so what base
against is perhaps this may be related
to d2 Auto receptor impairments and
sensitivity they're the less sensitive
and what this would mean is normally the
d2 Auto receptor plays a role in terms
of feedback mechanisms in terms of
regulating the release of presynaptic
dopamine so indeed if it were less
sensitive what that would mean is
there's actually an increase in the
release of presynaptic dopamine so
that's one potential mechanism that
might play a role in terms of why
ventral striatum dopamine activity might
be perhaps enhanced in this population
we're going to go on to a slightly
different mechanism now I'm just looking
at my dopamine transporter and a level
of Australian and one of the most
effective ways in which straddle
dopamine is its activity is terminated
is actually that it's taken up via the
dopamine transporter back into the
neuron and then and then deactivated so
that's how that's how the activity is
actually terminated in the synapse and
it's now actually several pieces of
evidence so at least three or four
studies to suggest that dopamine
transporter levels in the striatum and
particularly the ventral striatum in
imple in those with impulse control
behaviors is actually decreased and
compared to Parkinson's controls okay
this is with similar levels of neuron
degeneration so it's not related to a
decrease in dopamine Terminal density
and what this might suggest then and
again I'm just showing an image here of
this decrease in dopamine transporter
density
in indeed there is a study that suggests
that this might actually precede the
exposure to do opinion agonists or
medications and indeed it might then act
as a potential biomarker or a predictor
for development of these behaviors so
what you'd expect then is if there's a
decrease in dopamine transporting
density you might then end up with
dopamine in the synaptic space that
might then actually much longer in time
but also have a wider spread in activity
so potentially these are some of the
different ways in which physiological
dopamine they'd actually act for much
longer and so a much greater enhancement
of the underlying physiological activity
so just to summarize that section we see
that chronically for doper increases
spontaneously active dopamine neurons
are the ones that are capable of
listening a phase of dopamine response
to were rewarding to an unexpected
rewarding stimulus we see that in the
ICD patient's is a decrease in d2 auto
receptor sensitivity we also see a
decrease in straddle dopamine
transporter density and this actually
precedes release in one study suggested
it precedes or occurs prior to drug
exposure so it isn't secondary to only
the drug exposure itself and there is
some evidence or some a hypothesis that
the dopamine agonist may potentially
interfere with negative prediction error
actively so now let's move into talking
about cognitive mechanisms and we're
going to ask what why someone would
choose something that's potentially
risky potentially rewarding and it's an
immediate choice and it's a poorly
considered choice and we'll walk our way
through this we're going to start by
talking about the rewarding activity and
certainly it fits very nicely in terms
of what we've just been discussing in
terms of an enhancement of physiological
did the mean activity we're going to
talk a little bit about rewarding visual
stimuli and then potentially learn
from learning from outcomes so this is
again work from Antonia's to fellow's
group and this is using 11 carbon Rocco
Klein PET scanning where the ligand
binds the d2 d3 receptor and if there's
an increased release of dopamine in the
synapse they can then decrease the
binding potential of binding potential
of rapper informant my apologies this is
actually from palapa chains group these
two this is this current slide here and
what you see here is the Parkinson's
controls compared to Parkinson's
patients with impulse control behaviors
and they're shown in various visual
rewarding to use and the ICD patients
have this enhancement in ventral
striatum release of dopamine so in blue
compared to band which you don't see
with in the dorsal striatum in indeed
the same group has also been studies
using functional MRI looking at the bold
response in response to different and
rewarding cues and what they see is
specific to sexual cues in those with
compulsive sexual behaviors which I
don't see with other types of rewarding
cues they see enhanced activity bolder
bolder spawns in the ventral striatum
and what they also report is that
there's this correlation with an
increase in sexual desire or wanting but
not necessarily of liking so this
willingness to potentially work for this
reward but not not necessarily because
they're enjoying it or obtain pleasure
from it and they've taken this to mean
that this might support an incentive
motivation hypothesis now this
particular set of studies is from
Antonio Ramos period and here they've
been looking at the Parkinson's patients
with gambling and without gambling
behaviors again they've been using
eleven carbon rack applied and looking
at the binding
potential in the context of either of
endogenous to opinion movies and here
this is a gamble task that they that
they've exposed the subjects to and
again it will discuss the gambled house
previously indeed the gamble task in the
ICV patient's is associated with an
enhancement or increase in release in
ventral striatum dopamine so you can see
this decrease here on the right in the
binding potential wrap you can drag
behind now what's particularly
interesting though is actually this
control world so the control is so these
are gambling patients and when they're
doing just a straightforward motor task
a straightforward control towns you
actually see that there's a decrease in
binding potential to rattle pride also
in that control task itself and that's
potentially intriguing and the authors
initially had explained this is being
related to low d2 d3 receptor binding or
receptor density in the striatum but in
fact there's been multiple studies now
to suggest actually even at baseline
without any task is no clear-cut
decrease change in d2 d3 receptor
density levels in the striatum and that
actually differs from what you'd expect
in general population you do indeed see
that
say for instance pathological gamblers
in general population you do see that
there's no clear-cut change or decrease
in d2 d3 receptor density that certainly
in terms of and say substance use
disorders and particularly something
like an feta mean you do see a decrease
in d2 receptor density be more in the
ventral striatum but this the other
implication of this decrease in binding
potential in the control task would also
suggest that in response to multiple
tasks we end up with this increase in
physiological yin beasts of ventral
striatum and that would suggest again
and in keeping with the idea of an
enhancement in physiological dopamine
release so this is a study that we did
looking at learning from
rewards and losses and here I'm going to
focus in particularly on the reward
domain so in this study subjects choose
between one of two stimuli one of which
was more likely to associated with
winning as compared to the other and
what you see here is that the ICD
patients when they're on medications are
learn much faster and from rewards as
compared to off medications which you
don't see as much in the Parkinson's
controls and when you then extract out
prediction error and the expected
prediction and a trial by trial basis
you see that there's an increase in
activity in the ICD patients associated
with prediction error and expected
prediction in the striatum there's been
a group that's also looked at this and
shown similar results with regards to
the reward domain the slightly divergent
results with regards are lost and so in
this particular task again the ICD
patients they see a single so here they
see a single stimulus and it's a
probabilistic classification so they
just need to choose from one of two
actions one of which is more likely to
be associated with winning with regards
to this particular stimulus and what the
answer show is again at least in the
reward domain fairly similar to what the
previous slide had shown which was an
increase in the number of optimal
choices in the reward domain but they
also show that the ICD patients are
perhaps and more impaired at learning
from punishment trials also and indeed
when they look at two different
computational models of fitting either a
Q learning algorithm or an actor critic
reinforcement learning algorithm they
see there the actor critic algorithm is
a better fit and what you see here is
that the ICD patients are actually more
impaired at learning from negative
prediction error so this is actually
very much in keeping with the idea that
dopamine
guests may be more likely to impair
learning from negative prediction errors
so just to summarize the section the ICD
patients have enhanced ventral striatum
dopamine release within multiple
contexts including reward cues gambling
times but also to a fairly
straightforward motor houses suggesting
that that this might be in keeping with
this kind of enhancement of underlying
physiological dopamine activity at least
in two studies we see this increase
greater optimal choices with regards to
reward outcomes and in loosen one study
we're seeing this possible sub optimal
choices with regards to lost outcomes
and this there's some evidence to
support impaired learning from negative
prediction error as a function of
dopamine agonist so now in this last
section I'm going to talk a little bit
about impulsivity and impulsivity
there's various different types of
impulsivity and it's fairly
heterogeneous we can break it up into
motor domains and decisional domains and
they have some overlapping networks but
indeed they are also discrete in terms
than networks and underline them in
chemistry so they are heterogeneous in
nature and in terms of the motor domain
on the left here with conflict and
response inhibition there are at least a
couple studies that have attempted to
test for conflict and also response
inhibition in the ICD patients with
Parkinson's and shown that this new
clear differences from Parkinson's
controllers so it's not clear that
there's an impairment in the motor
domain what we predominantly see is
actually impairing the decisional domain
so with regards to delay discounting
risk-taking and reflection and facility
I'm going to walk you through some of
those so let's first start out with
talking about risk-taking this is a very
nice rodent study for
study from Celeste Napier's group in
which rodents were selecting from a
small certainly burn which the rodent
would definitely get one pellet or they
select from a larger risky tell it and
be very which they potentially could get
foreign pellets but we're decreasing
probability and what you see here is
that new pramipexole increases the
preference for this large risky river or
greater risk taking but there's actually
no effect of the parkinsonian lesion
itself so the six hydroxy dopamine's the
dorsal lateral striatum so there's no
clear-cut effect from Parkinson's
disease it's just an effect of the
dopamine agonist resolve and indeed when
you look at human studies and this is
looking at risk-taking in the context of
ambiguity so meaning that the risk is
without knowing the exclusive
probabilities so it's in the context of
uncertainty and this is called the
balloon and a lot of this task or the
barns and the subject squeezes the
balloon so that it increases and as it
increases in size you gain more money
but there's also a greater risk of it
bursting and this is from Dan Clawson
and what you see here is that the
Parkinson's patients with impulse
control behaviors are much more
risk-taking whether on dopamine agonist
so they're much more likely to increase
the size the balloon and indeed from Dan
Weintraub he's also scanned this
particular tasks using arterial spin
late in which gives you sort of baseline
activity and what you see here is the
Diaw CD patients and she have a decrease
or lower ventral stride like tivity when
they're performing this task as compared
to healthy controls over Parkinson's
patients without ICD we've also looked
at this task or looked at risk-taking
behaviors but using a slightly different
task and here we're asking people to
choose between a sure choice and a
gamble okay so this is the area in red
is the potential that you could win
money
yellow the potential that you might not
win any money and but what's important
is that this extra sure choice in the
gamble choice are actually of equal
expected value meaning that if you're
picking randomly to pick that 50% or if
you're pitching rationally you should
pick it about 50% and what you actually
see is that the Parkinson's patients
when they're the ones with impulse
control behaviors are much more
risk-taking in the game domain but not
in the roster name indeed when you scan
this particular task we see a very
similar result to dense Weintraub's
findings which are that you see a
decrease in ventral strider lack tivity
in the ventral striatum and the orbital
frontal cortex so both of these regions
involved in representation of Liske are
actually decreased in activity in the
eyes and in patients so we're going to
now move into talking about this
selection of impulsive choice or delay
discounting so wanting something
immediately that's actually quite a
small the word as compared to being able
to delay gratification for a much larger
delayed reward and again this is work
again from celeste Napier's group in
which six hydroxy dopamine has been
infused into the dorsal lateral striatum
so again a parkinsonian rodent model and
what they see with intracranial self
stimulation is that the lesion rats
actually have a preference for the
immediate reward so they have greater
delay discounting as a function of only
and solely the the lesion within the
dorsal lateral striatum so suggesting
that Parkinson's disease may potentially
be playing the role in terms of
enhancing delay discounting irrespective
of the exposure to dopaminergic
medications and indeed this is similar
to what we see actually in human studies
so this is one study in which
this is unmedicated Parkinson's disease
compared to healthy controls you can see
that this this is increase in delay
discounting compared to healthy controls
in Parkinson's patients who have not yet
started medications
this is Justin as something about the
underlying Parkinson's neurobiology is
actually contributing to an increase in
delay discounting whether that's
necessary dopaminergic or noradrenergic
again remains to be seen that the work
from from the lesion the dopaminergic
nasion and dorsal are destroyed and
might suggest that they may be little
community etiology and this concept of
delay discounting is very well
established in the substance abuse
literature so we see impaired delay
discounting across multiple substances
and behavioral addictions indeed in this
what we end up asking is things like do
you prefer smaller amount today like $11
today or do you prefer a much larger
amount thirty dollars in seven days and
what I'm showing here is pathological
gamblers in a general population being
much more likely to discount delayed
rewards as compared to controls and it's
actually been known multiple studies at
least three or four studies looking at
delay discounting and impulse control
behaviors in Parkinson's so this is the
most robust finding in impulse control
behaviors in Parkinson's and this is
from the Dominions study so you can see
that sample size is factually quite
large at least more than 50 or so per
subtype of behavior as compared to 282
parkinson's controls and here we're
talking again about subtitles so here
we're seeing that those who had
compulsive shopping are much more likely
to delay discount or discount delayed
rewards and have greater impulsive
choice as compared to Parkinson's
controls and this a bit of a trend with
the gamblers we don't see anything with
those who are binge eaters or high
perceptual and what that's telling us is
that someone say for instance who
presents the office whose mail there's a
high novelty seeker or
behind and delay discounting may be more
likely to gamble for instance where
someone who is female low in novelty
seeking low-end delay discounting may be
more likely to binge eat as compared to
song so it's starting to kind of tease
out differences with regards to to
behavioral subjects let's move now into
talking about how the choices are
considered so poorly considered choice
and here this is looking at the amount
of evidence you accumulate before you
make a decision so it's also called
reflection impulsivity
so this is the idea of someone who say
might spend ages on the internet looking
up different types of mobile phones or
cell phones before they buy one as
compared to somebody else who just walks
into a store and buys one immediately so
this is the concept of reflection
impulsiveness view and here you can test
this using something called the beans
test or the beets and the jar test in
which one of the jars is associated with
a higher proportion of red beads
compared to the leads to 80% red
compared to 20% believe with the
opposite contingency in the other jar
and you're just told that the computer
is going to pick from one of the jars
and it's going to show you a bead at a
time until you've made a decision about
which are the computers picking from in
this case you can see here the red bead
or red lead and someone who's very
impulsive might make a decision after
two beads and someone who's less
impulsive might make a decision after
1520 beans and what this study shows
again I'm missing a few bits here and
there I think it's a transition from
that to something else what you see here
is that the ICD patients make much more
are much more impulsive on this domain
so they pick fewer beans very similar to
substance use disorders we also see that
there's no clear differences with
regards to gamblers and Parkinson's
controls so here are the ICD patients of
impaired reflection
so dirty so just to summarize the
section we see that pramipexole
increases risk-taking in rodents with no
clear-cut effect from Parkinson's
animals and that the ICD patients when
they're on medications are much more
risk-taking with the regards to delay
discounting though received both in
effect of the parkinsonian rodent model
so Parkinson's itself plus also the
effect of the dopamine agonists in fact
we see that in in terms of the
parkinsonian lesion we see that both in
a rodent model and also the unmedicated
Parkinson's disease both of those
enhance delay discounting and it seems
has be some subgroup differences with
regards to delay discounting
particularly in shoppers and Anwar's we
see that the ICD patients the greater
reflection impulsivity as compared to
their controls we don't see any
differences in the motor domain and so
there's no clear cut in differences in
terms of the Stroop or the sloth signal
tasks and it may be that's this
decisional impulsivity is much more
likely to implicate particularly the
ventral striatum regions whereas
conflict and response inhibition may be
slightly different regions that are
involved perhaps more mesial striatal
perhaps more hyper direct pathways to
the subthalamic nucleus so slightly
different kind of mechanisms that might
be involved in terms of these cognitive
mechanisms indeed this actually is
highly relevant with regards to deep
brain stimulation targeting the
subthalamic nucleus but again just in
the interest of time I'm going to leave
that section so this is the last bit and
just highlight a little bit about
treatment issues there are case series
to suggest decreasing or discontinuing
the dopamine agonist
can be potentially effective in in some
of these patients although it's actually
can be very difficult for people to
tolerate there is a risk of dopamine
agonist withdrawal syndrome that's been
highlighted in unknown
burg and what we see is the ICB patients
are a greater risk of developing missed
stereotypes withdrawal syndrome
associate with anxiety craving dysphoria
autonomic symptoms it's a fairly similar
to what we expect in terms of a
withdrawal syndrome from stopping a
substance of other glues and it also
suggests that there's likely
sensitization effects with regard
students medications there are some
evidence for amantadine being
potentially effective in a randomized
controlled trial study in a small group
of patients but again there's a little
bit of a uncertainty because in the
Dominions study it's also been shown to
be associated with impulse control
behaviors this is a very nice study from
David O KY suggesting a cognitively
about therapy can in a randomized
control study be effective for global
symptom severity in the ICD patients and
Parkinson's and there's some evidence
for the use of naltrexone which is an
opioid antagonist and it seems to
improve my randomized control trial
study impulse control symptoms but not
necessarily global symptom severity so
now I'm just going to conclude the icds
are relatively common they occur in
about 14% of Parkinson's patients and
dopaminergic medications and certainly
it's something that patients caregivers
and clinicians should be quite sensitive
to this is mixed interaction between
individual vulnerability the potential
role for Parkinson's disease interacting
with a bunch of medications and these
parkinsonian the more recent studies
suggest that Parkinson's disease may
itself be playing a role particularly
from parkinsonian rodent model studies
showing that enhancement in the
reinforcing properties of dopaminergic
medications there seems to be an
abnormal regulation of dopaminergic
function which might be enhancing on
physiological dopamine activity and we
can see that chronically fado per for
instance
increases spontaneous dopamine neuron
activity where the proportion of
spontaneous neurons that are activated
we also see a decrease in d2 auto
receptor sensitivity and then decrease
in dopamine transporter density at the
level of the strontium and this results
or is manifested in an increase in
stride of dopamine release an activity
to reward use we also see it to other
contexts like a gambling task unexpected
and expected rewards we see greater
decisional but not necessarily motor
impulsive 'ti so we see greater list
taking delay discount in reflection
impulsivity potentially implicating more
ventral striatum regions and again we
also see that deep brain stimulation
targeting the subthalamic nucleus may
potentially improve impulse control
behaviors but unbalanced it doesn't seem
to improve and may perhaps exacerbate
and overeating type behavior so specific
to food rewards anyway thank you so I
think I'm going to end here and I
apologize because of timing issues I'm
not able to take any questions and very
much apologized
thank you
thank you dr. hoon and thank you to our
sponsor and our technology for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I would like to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing until
September 2016 you will receive an email
from lab rooms letting you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye